debout
l'adjudant chef john kelly
l élément le plus dangereux et le plus
efficace
qu'on est sur le terrain
il a presque autant de morts à son actif
que deux médailles
quelqu'un devrait vous parlez calme
quitte à terminer ce que tu avais à
faire on a besoin de toi sur le terrain
adjudant-chef qu'elle est il semblerait
que vous ayez un ennemi commun avec les
états unis
ils m'ont tout pris
ma famille
je n'ai plus rien
il prévoit une série d'attaqués
stratégique aux quatre coins du monde
nous devons réagir je veux faire partie
de l'équipe lieutenant-commandant vous
dirigerez la mission
seiya n'est pas favorable à la poursuite
d'une enquête sur le meurtre de sa femme
[Musique]
il n'avait pas le droit de me prendre
tout ce que j'avais
pour va tenter le tout pour le tout
jeune homme
mais soit annulée ils savaient
exactement où en serait
[Applaudissements]
tu peux me dire cette infection mortelle
c'est quoi ta position gênante
ils ont fait venir la gare jusque chez
moi
on peut y jouer avec mes règles
maintenant
[Musique]
aucun remords 14 16